[Music]
all right so I'm the first person to put
my hand up and say that I make the
visitor games on new generation consoles
jerks all the time and while there's
some truth to that the game selection on
ps4 and Xbox one has gotten way better
as a result here's some games that I
reckon are actually worth buying a ps4
to play stay tuned in two weeks from my
xbox one episode first up is powerful oh
how I love powerful and I swear it's not
just because I'm crazy competitive and
I'm actually fairly good at the game
okay it's a little bit because of that
as my favorite of the games whose names
and in full tower full is a great pixel
horrific indie game that has you
employing tactics or in my case blind
look to be the last man standing you
only have a few hours each but you can
pick up your missed shots along with a
whole lot of crazy power-ups or just use
double jumps and wall jumps to stomp on
other people's heads which makes the
Dead happen best served with a side of
at least a couple of friends tower full
has you cussing and cheering with the
best of them in the fast-paced action
platforming gameplay as for why it's
worth getting on ps4 the control feel
exceptional and gathering around the
console is the most fun way to play
towel now we can talk about games that
would make you wanna buy a ps4 without
actually talking about ones that appear
sport exclusive take for example the
epicness that is infamous second son
don't pass it off as just another
open-world game because I know there's
quite a few out there at the moment but
there's a lot about infamous that really
makes it unique you play as a super hero
which means you have a large variety of
different superpowers a big focus on
satisfying close quarters combat and
awesome ways to traverse Seattle
including a smoke - and a neon run all
of which actually make you feel like a
superhero second son also continues with
the series good evil kamma system which
has an impact on your powers and the
native like any good open-world game it
also has a bunch of side activities to
keep you busy but thankfully not enough
to wear you out it should also be said
that the game simply looks freaking
gorgeous so gorgeous this Sucker Punch
updated the game to include a further
mode so you can take as many screenshots
of your character shooting pink neon
bolts in front of epic orange sunsets as
you like somewhat of these choice and
another ps4 exclusive is side-scrolling
shoot-'em-up resogun resogun was one of
the few seriously solid ps4 launch
titles and pretty much the only game
that ps4 early adopters were playing
when the system was released the
nostalgic feel of old-school arcade
games will probably be the first thing
that grabs you shortly followed by the
fast-paced gameplay and the enemy types
and power-ups which are diverse enough
to keep the relatively simple mechanics
interesting since this one is only
available on ps4 as your fairly obvious
reason why this one might be worth
buying it for and the system is leverage
to produce an overwhelming amount of
particle and voxel effects also sick
neon visuals and blowing [ __ ] up
one of the loveliest idols to make its
way over to the ps4 is transistor you
can pick this one up on your PC too if
you're so inclined but if you want to
kick back on your sofa with an isometric
action RPG accented by an enticing
soundtrack and gorgeous visuals you
don't need to look any further
transistors the sort of game that hooks
you at first glance and does a really
good job of keeping you invested the
combat is unique and tactical enough it
never feels like me a button mashing the
combat system requires real-time and
turn-based mechanics and is supplemented
with skill trees and RPG elements to
keep your approach to the action your
orange just play it seriously play this
one the ps4 and Xbox one may have
started out with a fairly sparse anan
the impressive game selection but it's
certainly getting a lot better visually
let me know in that commenting section
which ps4 game is your favorite at the
moment and be sure to join me again in
two weeks where I'll have my Xbox one
picks last week I'm the gist I talked to
you guys about how watchdogs may be able
to win over essence greed haters and
here's what you reckons I see
conspiracies wanted it noted that he
loves the modern-day parts of Assassin's
Creed and so do an awful lot of other
people consider it known AC conspiracies
not all of you with that keen for watch
dogs including experiment what Stubbs
just feels to Ubisoft it's like it's
literally just Assassin's Creed in hacks
or future it's also a lot planned during
every aspect including visuals sand
Black Flag as well Oh cry 3 do more of
that Ubisoft let me know if you agree or
disagree along the same lines and reppin
my favorite comment of last week's spot
in X 169 X said watchdogs was originally
named assassin's dogs order but it was
too many words it sounds like a cool
game we'll get it at some point
I wouldn't definitely have bought that
game that is it for me this week be sure
to leave me all of your thoughts and
feelings and join me again in two weeks
after e3 for our next episode
you